okay so we built a an annual conference
for the y CIA this year this is the big
conference and we structured it to have
themes that crossed science and policy
government and industry right that was
the intent the original intent of the YC
I of the the climate energy institute
was to fold in these forces in society
into one into one theme and to educate
everybody across those lines okay so we
didn't shy away from it this year and we
attempted to mix science with with folks
interested in policy and an industry
which you know everybody thought was a
bad idea but i think it's a it's i think
it was a successful idea and we'll see
in about a week whether whether people
appreciate it or not okay and so there
were three topics that we're going to
explore in the conference that we're
going to explore today and the topics
have to do with genetics and bioenergy
so we're exploring three topics in the
energy sector genetics and bioenergy
production of energy through altering
the genetic information and organisms
solar fuels which is using in this case
production of hydrogen directly through
using solar energy and and then battery
since energy storage so today's talks
will cross those topics Andre Taylor
we're going to talk about batteries in
energy storage and Jordan pecha will
talk about genetics and bioenergy and so
if I'd have to decide then Jordan you'd
be able to go first please and I just
want to note that this effort was
not just today but the the evolution of
the conference has been a tremendous
effort that was driven by by students
okay well I should say it was driven by
me yelling at students and and I want to
note danina hotspots key yes did I get
it right and you fill sow Brian Mars
who's been a great inspiration and
Joseph Edgar's who's been a great kids
brush you can raise your hand job there
you go these guys that have really
worked very hard to get this together
yoni Cohen is also involved and I don't
see him here okay and so know that for
the students in the audience that if
you're if you want to get involved in
this and you want to help this is really
a great opportunity to to interact with
top scientists and industry folks and
government folks and so I recommend
getting involved anyway I think we'll
get started right so thank you very much
for inviting me to talk and I'll try and
keep it to 15 minutes or less so through
today I'd like to tell you a little bit
about biofuels and genetics the group
that that is working on this in my lab
is with um hameed wisma niazi brought
kasnije dark blue Darrell reefs from
computational biology and bioinformatics
and PhD student Kyle Bibby and I think I
received a lot of information on what to
talk about some said talk very broadly
about things others had talked about
your research and yet another comment
said talk about the efforts at Yale so
it kind of woven all those in since his
15 minute talk according to the
Department of Energy the demand for
liquid fuels used in the United States
transportation is projected to remain
constant over the next 20 years or so
with petroleum derived gasoline diesel
and jet fuel comprising nearly 90
the demand the idea that they're
thinking about here is that although
we're going to offset some of the liquid
fuel that we need because of
battery-powered cars and better
efficiency and cars and planes and
diesel-powered vehicles there we're
still going to grow and we're going to
need more of them and so we still need
to be thinking about liquid
transportation fuels well I this is a no
policy talk and I hopefully I don't get
stuck talking too much about when peak
oil production will will happen to occur
in the world but during this i know that
this graph is about is a couple years
old and i think they already said that
it's going to happen and i haven't heard
anything about it but there is no doubt
that at some point peak oil production
will occur and at some point the demand
for oil is going to cross that peak oil
production and then oil is going to cost
a lot more gas is going to cost a lot
more so we can grow things and we can
turn them into liquid fuels and this
sounds like a pretty good alternative
this is a kind of a big messy plot and
it suggested you starting out with solar
ray radiation we can get all over at
least somewhere along here to liquid
fuels and the path we take can be many
many fold we can start with things like
solid biomass we can look at sugars and
plants we can take something like algae
or oil or soybean rich atrophic some we
can process into oil that can be trimmed
esterified into into diesel fuel others
can be fermented like sugar into ethanol
of butanol etc and then some can be done
by a you know have you due to chemical
processes like pyrolysis and then
through something like Fisher troph to
get to to liquid fuels the one I want to
talk about today and the one that we
work on most of my lab is is algae this
is one of that maybe hopefully key
solutions to some of the liquid fuel
problems that we find ourselves in right
now so algae are photosynthetic we're
interested in algae because they are
very very efficient harvester
photosynthetic solar energy they reduce
carbon dioxide and growth in an
autotrophic cycle and we don't want to
say that its carbon neutral but they
certainly can offset their it's
certainly an offset there let's see how
do you can be used for a lot of
different things they can use for
aquaculture feed they can be used for
electricity generation in solid fuels we
they can produce a lot of starch and use
them from bio ethanol production they
could produce a lot of lipids and we can
use them in diesel fuel they produce
really nice things like vitamins a c
they make phytosterols they make
beta-carotene they make vitamin E
there's a big list they make a lot of
nice stuff and when we stretch them they
even do better and I guess that's kind
of a global lesson here's a plot a lot
of different literature put together of
microalgae in an unstressed condition
these are the clear circles and in a
stress conditions these were the dark
gray circles and if you put an average
on that we see that by weight they can
make about forty five percent lipid
content and most of these extra lipids
or triglycerides that can be directly
transits terrified into it's a diesel
fuel versus when they're not stressed
stress can be it can it can be extra it
can be too much light it can be nitrogen
deprivation it might even be sulfur
deprivation there's it can be different
temperatures I mean the general rule or
the general comment that people like to
say is microalgae beets corn palm and
soil and that's because the lipid
content her out of the biomass can be a
lot higher and there's also greatly
reduced acreage than the estimates for
producing a lot of liquid fuels we could
make all that we're just taking the
basic sort of estimates now what we can
do with microalgae if we take Montana
provided Montana was hot all day all
year long and we turned it into a big
pond
we'd be set that's probably not feasible
but it's it's it's it's better than what
we're going to get if we do this with
corn let's see there's a faster growth
rate and there's ostensibly better
sustainability metrics although there's
a lot of argument here about how much
nitrogen is used how you can recycle
nitrogen what needs to be done for
energy inputs to compress carbon dioxide
a lot needs to be worked out there's
many life cycles now assessments on
microalgae and we've learned a lot of
things from those like cycle cycle
assessments the upshot is is that we're
not quite there yet we don't have a real
good algae production process and so I
think our life cycle assessment still
need to grow as we develop it but
overall and the reason we're interested
in genetics is because you know we're a
long ways from beating oil production if
algae made oil in the ground and we
could pump it out we would do that but
unfortunately right now l is gasoline is
still less expensive than bottled water
in the United States and we've got to do
something to make the production of
microalgae that well genetic approaches
can help they can help in a few ways
microalgae did not evolve for us to use
them to make biofuels they have some
nice characteristics that we can exploit
but if we want them to do exactly what
they need to do in order to make a more
economic biofuel we're going there
genetic engineering is at least in play
if you want to say that it's not in play
we still need to know a lot about the
genetics of microalgae in order to
optimize growth regimes feeding regimes
etc so our lab sort of looked at this in
a three-fold way we look at biochemical
engineering we're doing transcriptomics
and then we apply bioinformatics to get
a lot of genetic information from these
microalgae and the reason that we're
doing this is because microalgae weren't
so cool like five years ago and when
everybody was genetic with sequencing
plants and bacteria and humans and fish
nobody was sequencing microalgae and
that's in it is partly because nobody
was interested or few people were
interested and it's also because
microalgae genomes are very large that
are not like bacteria they're 100 to 200
times bigger than bacteria 100 mega
bases they're like a plant and even
though we can sequence faster than we
used to it still takes a lot to sequence
of genome and if we don't have the
janome we don't have the blueprints a
compromise to do that is to sequence
only the transcribe between teams in
that analogy these are the ones we care
about in the first place and we call
that the transcriptome so if we take
microalgae and we grow them under lots
of different conditions this is analogy
dunno y el a turkey elect them it's a
seawater algae it produces a lot of
lipids it produces a lot of starts and
it produces a lot of nice things like
like beta carotene and you can see after
multiple days of growth if you starve it
of nitrogen you get a difference in
growth curves you can do the same thing
with salinity the growth curves don't
change much but when you look at the
production's the type of things that
they make you'll notice that the average
lipid content won't change with nitrogen
deprivation but the starch content will
change it'll double actually when you
deprive them of starch there's also some
some changes in changing the molarity in
the strength of saline solution that
they're grown in and taken all together
what we can do is we can grow them under
lots of different conditions so they
express lots of different genes those
genes are out there and express we can
take that RNA turn it into DNA
sequencing so let's just focus on this
middle section the details are on both
sides to say how do we do this but we're
taking advantage of next-generation
sequencing technologies we started off
with 454 pyrosequencing now we move to
alumina pyrosequencing where we get a
lot more reads for for less money
extract RNA turn it into DNA these are
the only expressed genes we normalize it
so we don't get too many peaks of one
gene versus another gene because we
don't want all our sequencing to go into
a gene that's expressed a lot we wanted
an old transcriptome we do some stuff to
make it work in the sequence
and then we sequence it those sequences
are short reads around 400 basis log and
we need to assemble them into longer
genes and assemble them eventually into
a transcriptome we use a lot of
different bioinformatics programs to do
that and to take these short sequences
overlap the nucleic acid sequences and
get them into longer genes so we have
transcripts we take those transcripts
and we sort of we blast them but we do
gene annotation we fight figure out what
they are and then we have now a long
list of transcripts in a sequence of
microalgae and here's the reason we'd
want to do this as I said before there's
only a few micro algae that have been
sequence and it turns out they're not
the ones that make a lot of stars in a
lot of lipid so if we want to take
advantage of what Mother Nature has
given us its analogy that can really
make a lot of lipids we're going to have
to do something different to get genomic
information from them so do nellie l has
never been sequenced and the other ones
that we're dealing with right now have
they been sequenced as well so we're
doing this transcript don't work here's
just a few kind of statistics on this
and what I want you to kind of focus on
the bottom is that we get nice coverage
34-30 full coverage over all of these
different genes so we get lice overlap
on them and a pretty good description of
the transcribed genes when we put those
against databases our organism looks
like an album that is the types of
sequences that it matches with best are
things from the few micro algae that
have been sequences their genomes bull
Vox and see Ryan Hardy when we start
annotating them very specifically and
looking how do they fit into pathways
we're able to sort of get some ideas of
generally how many enzymes are in a
pathway known enzymes and how many
sequences we can find fitting those
pathways so this is this is the Calvin
cycle we found 12 of the 13 sequences
generally in the calvin cycle this is
triglyceride synthesis we found five of
the six for fatty acid biosynthesis we
found 14 or 14 we found all the starts
enzymes as well and when you do that you
can start assembling them into pathways
now we know pathway for starch synthesis
we know the pathway for fatty acid
synthesis and how they
feeds into triglyceride synthesis we're
working now to make these quantitative
so we can look at the different
expression levels of not just one gene
but of multiple pathways and how the
pathways prior to that feed into it
because if you want to genetically
engineer something you can't just say oh
look here's the first gene in the
triglyceride pathway let's just over
express that see what happens it's not
good what you have to think about is how
all the genes need to be expressed and
you have to also think about how the
carbon is partitioned in the microalgae
into that expression so there's many
many different steps there's probably
going to be a lot of different genetic
engineering oh ok done in order or in
order to make these microorganisms do
what we want them to do so so you've
never popular if we show a lot of
pathways just want to show you that we
were able to describe the starch pathway
very well as also so ongoing research in
our lab right now is that we're just now
getting to the point where we're making
this work quantitative and there's some
tricks because you can do this
quantitatively in something like the
human genome where you have this janome
template we don't have any full genome
templates for these microalgae right now
so we have to make the template first
through the transcriptome and then find
a way to get the software to work in
order to sort of add up all those
different transcribe copies of
transcribed genes but hopefully that
will happen soon we're doing this not
only in denali ella but in other
candidate microalgae like senna Decimus
by amorphous and neo chlorosis óleo
abundance right we're also making them
dance we're doing all kinds of things
we're adding nitrogen taking away
nitrogen we've got different methods of
putting on keto more or less baking them
very high incident radiation and and we
can make them grow in a very dense
pattern we can make them make a lot of
lipids a little bit of lipids and
through all of those different tests and
we look at the trend the quantitative
transcriptome we get a good idea about
how they're taking care of business when
they make more lipids we now hopefully
will be in a very good position very
soon to understand how they're making
those more little
lipids and we'll be able to exploit
those procedures the activities that
Yale right now I mean there's lots of it
and I'm sure I've missed I've missed
some of them but some that are quite
active in in the biofuel production
arena is Julie Zimmerman in poly
nastiest at the Center for green
chemistry they're doing things like
designing chemical surfactants for the
polar microalgal lipids the ones that we
don't use in biofuels Julie is working
on supercritical fluid extraction and
better ways to get lipids out of these
microalgae which is a large barrier and
then also on lifecycle analysis so of
course we know Scott strobel he's got
his michael diesel microorganism and and
he sequence that genome I know and he's
put together pathways for that as well
Rob Bayless works a lot in stainless
sustainability of biofuel production in
developing countries and I think the
trophy I know specifically and then you
know something that ties all this work
together in the new a large amount of
sequence as we get is somebody like Mark
gerstein and bioinformatics who was very
helpful and putting all this work
together
okay so the way this business is done is
to take some organism and to stress it
right and then to under that and then to
you know produce well in this case
you're looking at producing biodiesel
right because your applique the assets
that's right so you're stressing it to
it under various conditions in order to
express a higher proportion of fatty
acids or triglycerides right that's
right and then you're mimicking that
expression through genetic alteration so
that it just produces this sort of thing
that's the natural state all right yeah
that's the idea so if we could if we can
perturb it some way that it produces
more lipids and it's going to it has its
own method for producing those more
lipids it and that's probably the most
stable way and then we look at the
express jeans and see how those pathways
arc stress we have a roadmap of how it
likes to do it naturally and then that's
what we would want to sort of turn on
permanently and her genetic engineering
and what's your best guess in terms of
maximum production by doing this you
know what can you what can you get out
of this yeah and my might my best guess
is yeah that's a hard one but i can say
reasonably that right now the
triglyceride production in micro algae
or the lipid overall lipid production is
his often around twenty thirty percent
and i see it very reasonably going up to
fifty percent and there are indeed
microorganisms that can do that already
but not constantly but i think you could
do that anymore you take away the carbon
from the rest of the organisms and it's
too harsh to tell a little bit about
solar fuels there was a previous meeting
that the students ran and james blake
more gave a talk at that at that meeting
some of you might have been there and i
think he talked a lot about the peas in
my research group works our solar solar
group in the chemistry department and
some of you might have heard that so i'm
going to focus my talk not so much on my
own research but more on
the issue of solar few are the issues
with solar fuels and I want to start out
by first a little bit of argument why
solar and why do we need fuels for solar
and then how do we make solar fuels and
what are the methods and what are the
pros and cons advantages and
disadvantage limitations for that and
then I'll just end with a brief maybe
introduction about what we're trying to
do in our own research group but I won't
focus much most of the time on that so I
probably don't have to say very much
about about solar energy but I thought
I'd just give a argument for renewable
renewables this is a paper that Dan
kamon rodin in Scientific American about
five years ago and it shows a pie chart
of where we get our energy at least as
of 2006 here's a coal oil and natural
gas and this little sliver is non
hydroelectric renewables and of that
little sliver blown up here that little
sliver is solar energy so we're getting
much much less than one percent of our
energies coming from solar energy right
now and it's even worse in the United
States this is global here's United
States coal oil and natural gas you can
see here's all the renewables including
hydroelectric there we're even worse in
the United States so we need we need to
focus on renewables and I think by
everybody's analysis the only renewable
energy that has the capacity to power
the planet of solar energy nuclear
potentially but I think nuclear is
rapidly losing favor with the problems
that their nuclear reactors are having
in Japan so for nuclear solar energy
into some of there's some sort of
snippets the others I should maybe go
back but point out that as of 2005 the
power the consumption global energy
consumption was about 16 terawatts it's
a little higher than that now and that's
about enough energy in one hour of
sunlight striking the surface of the
earth to power the planet for a year if
we could collect it and in fact
photosynthesis is how is is basically
harvesting about 90 terawatt see
at the present time that's of course in
a renewal a cyclic process we're not
storing biomass at that amount but they
are collecting solar energy at that
level so how can we do it and so this is
a picture you probably have seen this is
a map of the plug of the globe showing
the solar energy intensity in terms of
watts per meter squared orange is high
high solar energy capacity blue and
violet low and you can see our regions
like the debt Sahara Desert and you know
much of Australia have a lot of solar
energy capacity and these little circles
represent arrow air areas that if we
summed up these six circles we would
have a capacity of generating 18
terawatts if we had ten percent
conversion efficiency for solar energy
it doesn't look all that uh you know
impossible to do oops go back again
impossible to do you know these these
are not insignificant areas for example
this circle the United States's is close
to the size of the state of Iowa and so
there was there's a pretty substantial
need for for surface area to do this and
that's at a ten percent of conversion
efficiency which is reasonable recently
good efficiency but as Nate Louis's
often said is that we paved over that
much of the United States already so if
we could make solar energy conversion
processes as cheap as asphalt we be in
business okay so that's what we're faced
with but so how do we do this we can
make electricity but the problem with
electricity is storage and the sunlight
is intermittent and and also electricity
has the disadvantage that transmission
over long distances have significant
losses and so we'd like to be able to
make fuel not only for transportation
fuels which jordan focused on but also
just as a way of storing solar energy
and so you know the idea here is we'd
have some solar energy collection
process and the conversion to fuel and
i'll talk about how that might be done
that allows us to store and we could be
fed back into fuel cells to make
electricity again if we wanted or
as transportation fuels and so that's
that's what we'd like to be able to do
so how do you do that what is fuel
basically fuel is a molecule that is in
its reduced form and is able to react
with oxygen and be release energy and in
any molecule that's in reduced form that
we react with oxygen work you know so
here's hydrogen but the currency of fuel
formation is electrons you need to have
a source of electrons in order to
generate fuel and on a global scale
there's only one source of electrons
that would meet the bill and that's
water so we have to learn how to split
water if we want to make fuel with solar
energy and this is the basic reaction if
you want to split water to make hydrogen
and oxygen and this is a decomposition
of two reactions we have to take water
and extract electrons from it and then
use those electrons to make fuel which
could be hydrogen that's the chemistry
of fuel formation and the hard part of
this is the water oxidation reaction
that's a hard reaction to do that's the
bottleneck in solar fuel formation and
it's been a focus of a lot of effort
over by many research groups over the
years to try to figure out efficient
ways to do water oxidation that's the
hard part of the reaction well there is
one way that this can happen that this
this is that this works and it works
extremely well and that was invented
about two and a half billion years ago
maybe more by nature and photosynthesis
and this is the overall reaction that
nature does it extracts electrons from
water water nature figured out that if
you want electrons on a global scale
you've got oxidized water so that's what
it does in oxygenic photosynthesis
oxygen is being produced that's created
anaerobic atmosphere currently about
twenty one percent oxygen in the
atmosphere the fuel that's made is
initially made by reducing carbon
dioxide so electrons extracted from
water are given to carbon dioxide to
make carbohydrates initially but then
all biomass comes from that and that's
the overall stoichiometric reaction for
photosynthesis that it's been occurring
in excess over the two and a half
billion years or so since
oxygen-evolving organisms first appeared
so that we have now twenty one percent
oxygen in the atmosphere it's buried
steam is its match stoichiometrically by
buried biomass that is
coral equivalent to that amount of
oxygen it fits it and and I get my
straight down and that varied biomass is
the fossil fuel so we're actually
powering the planet on solar fuels right
now and it's in the form of fossil fuels
and to give you some idea of the
magnitude of this we've been burning
these fossil buried biomass fossil fuels
for hundreds of years and at an
increasing rate and we haven't changed
the oxygen concentration in the
atmosphere at all or not significantly
what what does that mean it means
there's a heck of a lot of very biomass
and we're not going to run out of fossil
fuels anytime soon the biggest issue is
carbon dioxide production and the issues
with with climate change associated with
that so we really are talking about two
things one is carbon free fuel and or
carbon neutral and and the the
production of these fuels using solar
energy so so how do we do that well
ideas for this have been kicking around
for a long time this is some of you
probably familiar with this paper that
was published in science in 1912 99
years ago by Giacomo shimmy Shawn and
I'll just read this quote to you from
this paper said on the arid lands there
will spring up industrial colonies
without smoke and without smokestacks
forests of glass tubes will extend over
the plains and glass buildings will rise
everywhere inside of these will take
place the photo chemical processes that
here there to have been the guarded
secret of the plants but will have been
mastered by human industry which will
know how to make them bear even more
abundant fruit than nature for nature is
not in a hurry and mankind is pretty
amazing that that was written nearly a
hundred years ago so that's what we're
aiming to do we still don't have a
process that can do this but that's the
goal and actually Jimmie Shannon was
pictures of him working in his his
laboratory which is back yard with all
kinds of flasks and things laying out
he's sitting out in the sunlight as he
was trying to come up with photo
chemical processes to convert solar
energy didn't succeed very well but he
certainly started the process okay so so
how do we do this so I'm going to focus
on two general ways that you could make
few
with solar energy one is an indirect
method to produce solar fuels so first
indirect method is let's make
electricity from photovoltaics we know
how to make photovoltaics we know how to
make electricity from sunlight it's
sitting on the top of Kroon Hall here
we're making electricity with silicon
photovoltaics and let's use that
electricity to electrolyze water and
make hydrogen so here are some solar
panels various pictures of them thanks
to James Blake more I stole them out of
here your PowerPoint presentation and
here's a picture of how you might
electrolyzer would work you have an
electrolysis process here's a volt
voltage that's generated by by a
photovoltaic and it's creating a voltage
that will create water oxidation at one
electrode surface water being converted
to oxygen that's generating electrons
which pass through the electrical
circuit and protons which have to be
passed from one interface to the next
and there was protons and electrons then
are being combined to produce hydrogen
at the so called cathode where the
reduction half of the reaction occurs so
that's the overall process and if we can
make electricity we can electrolyze
water this is something we all did as
kids right and works works just fine so
it and the advantages of this indirect
method is that we have known technology
we know how to make photovoltaics we
know how to electrolyze water it has
another advantage in terms of fuel
production is that you could imagine
coupling large solar arrays with a
centralized fuel production module that
would enable more efficient fuel
collection one of the disadvantages of
having fuel that's produced over you
know acres and acres of land is how do
you how do you collect it you know so
you talk about extraction processes but
you know those are extremely yeah in the
engineering of that is going to be
really difficult you also in this kind
of a scheme have the potential that you
could imagine individual fuel production
on each of our rooftops we could have
solar panels on our roof and we could
make hydrogen and r you know store it in
our house and then at night we'd have
fuels that available to generate
electricity at night when the sun's not
shining and so that's that's certainly
an advantage and another advantage is
that it's already possible to have
overall high efficiency greater than ten
percent
overall conversion efficiency
photovoltaics commercial photovoltaics
are in the fifteen percent to twenty
percent efficiency conversion efficiency
range electrolyzers the best ones have
about eighty percent conversion
efficiency so we we can imagine pretty
high conversion efficiencies and you
know that this is something that is very
critical in conversion efficiency
correlates with how much land area do
you need to collect solar energy and
that's a big issue with many processes
and it's also a big issue with biofuels
because plant conversion efficiency is
quite low so we need much much bigger
land area for biofuel production with
current efficiencies we need to ramp up
those efficiencies to make these good
good enough and so this already is
possible with with photovoltaics the
disadvantage the court why aren't we
using photovoltaics it's economics yeah
Georgia showed 300 a half dollar maybe
knots closer to four dollars a gallon
that's really cheap we don't have any
technology that can make fuels that
cheap and so we these are very expensive
another if we would use this indirect
method where we got large solar arrays
that are coupled to catalysts turn
electrolysis processes you need good
catalysis has to go very fast to keep up
with larger rays of solar energy so
catalysts development becomes an issue
for this that's chemistry and another
disadvantage is that you you make lots
of junctions and you transfer
electricity over larger distances and
you're going to get losses from
electrical and junction resistances so
those are issues that are perhaps
disadvantages for this indirect method
so obviously if there's an indirect
method there must be a direct method
right and so what's the direct method
that's what photosynthesis does
photosynthesis uses light this is a
cartoon picture taken from the
University Illinois down arts lab where
you have photo chemical processes that
are directly using light to oxidize
water and using the electrons generated
to reduce carbon dioxide in the calvin
cycle so this is a direct process where
these oxidation reactions of reduction
reactions are directly coupled to the
photo chemical processes and in and
we're going to hear from nate lewis that
are at our annual conference coming up
about his his
his Center the Joint Center for
artificial photosynthesis which is
housed at Caltech or centered at Caltech
he's leading this effort and has been
awarded the goe solar fuels hub award is
as a 125 million dollar grant they just
landed last year to develop processes
for solar fuel production and he'll tell
us about that in his talk but basically
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to generate processes that are
going to give direct production of solar
fuels so here's the sort of a schematic
of the idea here it's not necessarily
exact arrangement they would use but
basically we have some kind of system
which is absorbing light and try and
creating a voltage that is directly
using used by catalysts that are on the
oxidation side to produce water oxygen
even for water and on the reduction site
to produce hydrogen so it's an all
integrated unit that would then generate
fuel formation hydrogen in the form of
fuel and oxygen by water splitting by
direct photo chemical conversion okay so
this sounds great and it what are some
of the advantages the advantages of
course you have the potential for high
very high efficiency you don't have all
these resistance losses that we might
imagine for the indirect method and you
have the idea possibility that you could
create a single solar fuel module that
would basically make fuel so that would
be great disadvantage this is unknown
technology really on how to do it yeah
that's the problem that's why they gave
125 million dollars to California to try
to come up with way to do this so we
don't have whether I would say is
totally unknown there are there are in
the research lab there are processes
that will do this but with very poor
efficiency you've nowhere close to ten
percent less than one percent efficiency
at even less than that and so that's a
problem we need some significant amount
of research to do this and it and
another disadvantage is that if you have
these integrated systems you're making
fuel everywhere over this entire solar
array you know if you're covering the
state of Iowa with a solar array how do
you collect that fuel into you know put
it into a pipeline or wherever we're
going to do it and so you've got this
decentralized fuel production with
larger raise it complicates fuel
collection so that's going to be a more
of an engineering issue but that's an
shoe that has to be dealt with as well
you know so where is it where is the
fuel field of solar fuels going well
most of the research right now is trying
to develop methods to do these processes
you know we need better methods for
integrating these systems better
catalysts to do these reactions and so
it's really at the at the level of
research right now and the goal of the
Joint Center for artificial
photosynthesis is actually to push the
research forward but then integrate them
into a functioning module and then
hopefully ramp up the efficiency
progressively and I think the benchmark
everybody talks about is about ten
percent efficiency if you really want to
have something that becomes commercially
viable you need to get up to about ten
percent efficiency to make it to make it
really fly well that's where that's what
solar fuel the field is and I'll just
end by saying we're trying to do some of
that research in our group here we have
a collaboration that involves four of a
research groups in four pies in
chemistry here's Charlie and Charlie's
in the audience are here Charlie Schmid
Meyer Bob Crabtree and Victor Batista
and myself and we're joining forces with
different expertise to try to develop
processes for solar fuel production by
improving catalysts and attaching them
to semiconductor materials for
photochemical reactions that could give
direct photochemical solar solar solar
fuel production and this is sort of the
idea here in at least in the research
lab this is a picture of a photo
electrochemical cell that actually Gary
Moore who's going to moderate our
session has been working on and has a
system actually makes fuel with sunlight
but efficiencies aren't high yet but the
idea is we would use a photochemical
process with catalysts that would split
water to release electrons or oxidized
water and generate use those electrons
to generating a fuel-like hydrogen so
that's what we're trying to do it's a
ongoing research effort and and I'm not
going to go into any more details on
that but I think that's where I'd like
to end about are what I have to say on
solar feels okay
hello thank you for the invitation to
come to this great kickoff meeting on
them very excited about the about the
work that's been taking place so so my
name is Andre Taylor and then where I'm
going to talk to you about energy
storage and batteries for the third
component of this kickoff so we had a
couple of purposes and the first purpose
that I was told is okay let's let's
provide the campus with a background
knowledge the techniques let's get the
campus excited about and prepared for
the conference let's generate possible
interdisciplinary research in the fields
among faculty courage students that go
into the fields and then next part to
say let's recap the central science of
the three conferences the topic areas
solar fuels you notice in biofuels and
then and then batteries then discuss
Yale's engagement to connect the science
overall system and by the way let's keep
this all within 15 minutes so I was kind
of struggling kind of putting this
together but I'm very excited because I
think each of these purposes are very
valuable here and I'm glad that we have
this this kickoff event with the
previous previous things so I wanted to
kind of divide the this area when we're
talking about batteries I wanted to kind
of divide this into three different
areas one is entertainment and
environment and health care and I'll
kind of circulate around these three
themes as kind of motivating factors for
battery technology and so how many of
you have heard of this company Korea
could by a show of hands who's who's
heard of this company no nobody in the
room nobody at all okay so good so I'm
talking about something that no one's
hurt so so this company Korea right here
so they're actually base right here so
of course there's there was there is the
unfortunate japanese earthquake that
happened a few weeks ago and actually
this place right here has seventy
percent of the global market share for
lithium polymer batteries so in fact
this the plant for Korea wasn't wasn't
actually torn apart but the port city
right here this ona Hama port city right
here has been damaged so they can't
export the material so according to
vishal sapru from the frost & sullivan
of wall street journal ii said you know
it's definitely gonna be a problem you
know then many mobile products you use
lithium polymer batteries and so how
does this affect everyone in this room
well it might affect people that use
portable electronics and then maybe no
more ipods ipads or iphones and that's a
very big conservative people that are in
technology so that's my entertainment
spin and motivation behind batteries for
this for this application now the issue
right here when we're talking about
sources and carriers is is what kind of
sources do we have what kind of carriers
can we put together and and and becomes
kind of a chicken egg type of type of
challenge so we have different sources
right here whether we started off with
with hydroelectric or coal moving
towards nuclear which might not be as
mentioned earlier as popular now solar
photovoltaics definitely biomass
conversion with what jordan's been
involved in and then also working with
conventional crude oil or wind power and
the problem is that we have these
abundant sources but then the carriers
of these of these sources becomes a
challenge and of course we've become
very very comfortable with gasoline
diesel matter of fact when we apply for
for grants you know a lot of the
military organizations you know can you
can you synthesize this JPA jp8 is there
is there fuel of choice because all of
their vehicles infrastructure can center
around that but this issue of hydrogen
and so there's there's there's different
hydrogen energy technology lab centers
on the part of one that that's sprung up
from from Michigan and one of the
problems with hydrogen is the storage of
Hydra so it's a great energy carrier but
but but storage of this is an issue
electricity of course that's great but
then how do you store electricity and
how do you actually have this
electricity available due to your point
on demand and with natural gas being in
the equation so we have yet min Qiang
who's who's coming in from from a one
two three and I just wanted to kind of
put this schematic up right here where
we talk about these different
efficiencies and so if you look at
efficiencies from crude oil to to to
your automobile so from a well to wheel
type of efficiency of course you go
through a series of steps right here
where you lower your efficiency right
here so whether you
mind the oil go through a refinery
system your internal combustion engine
which what multiples of a drive right
here and then down to your wheel for
transportation it's about twenty percent
efficient if you look at this other
route pathway right here where if you're
going through for example a power plant
and so electric vehicles are great right
but then if you're plugging an electric
vehicle in your wall and if it's being
powered by oil or by a coal-fired plant
then how does that actually impact your
your input on the environment but of
course you can still say that you can
get 100 miles per gallon but there's
some very very interesting things that
can actually take place and and with yet
being with a one two three that they're
developing these vehicles and if you can
imagine when we talk about large area
energy storage and if you imagine a
whole fleet of cars that can store
energy now you might be able to talk
about distributed energy where these
cars could maybe have solar panels or
that sort of thing on the surface or
they can be plugged in whereas during
high capacity you could store
electricity and then maybe use that for
your vehicle to transmit home so very
very interesting pathway right here this
pathway right here that we have is about
twenty-five percent efficient and the
area that I've that our group has been
active in as in fuel cells so of course
fuel cells are more efficient but then
also there's different challenges one of
the main challenges is where do you do
with your fuel and the preferred fuel of
choice is hydrogen but of course
hydrogen of course what the problems
with storage there's there's been some
breakthrough papers with people that
have created metal-organic frameworks so
forth that can give higher storage
capacity but the problem is is is that
those capacities aren't nearly as high
as what they need to be and so in terms
of fuel processing there is a tremendous
amount of work a few years ago I guess
that maybe in the in the late 90s early
change of the millennium is is is in
this fuel processing and one of the
problems with fuel processors is that if
you want to supply fuel for for fuel
cell you have to go through all these
conversion steps so you have to go
through a reforming step water gas shift
preferential oxidation and all those
steps to get rid of the impurity for
such a CEO or sulfur and in order to
feed that to a fuel cell but again these
these are some of the issues that routes
right here between
energy conversion energy storage and so
there's there's some issues right here
there's there's motivation and I like
the point that the Gary brought out is
that we're not going to run out of fuel
anytime soon I mean it's it's just not
going to happen and so whether you're
talking about if whether its
environmental motivation or whether
you're talking about whether it's these
high prices there is some sort of
motivation to to look two words energy
storage applications I think money is
the main motivating factor because once
gasp moves up to five dollars i think
people go into a panic and then that's
when we start hearing more people the
politicians and and and so forth talking
about what we need to do something so i
think that's a major issue so just to
introduce you to my group right here so
so we stroll across Yale's campus right
here and these are some of my group
members and also we have a new group
member here sylvie sent apa' we just
joined our group a couple weeks ago and
so actually what we what we do is we
think about these kinds of issues so
working in the energy storage is of
course Sylvie also forest is we have to
get a better shot of him he's he's kind
of camera shy a little bit but he's
actually in the audience out here and he
actually gave a talk earlier about about
batteries and I think it was a good talk
from from the feedback that I received
and of course we have Marcelo Ryan tango
a joke I who's also in our group and
they work on various things so to kind
of introduce you to my group and the
things that we do just to kind of
promote a little bit of synergy and I'm
very excited about this opportunity
because I think you know I don't think
our group has done enough work on our
and to make it up the hill to see what
people are doing and I think it's kind
of goes both ways but maybe with these
kind of activities we can kind of find
out more of the research I start
building these these kind of alliances
so our area right here so our philosophy
right here is our group focuses on the
design and assembly of systems that
renewably improve our way of life many
of these systems require high
performance nanomaterials for energy
conversion and storage so what are some
of the areas we work in so we work in
organic solar cells we have a full OPV
line where we're actually building a
solar test station to go inside so we
can fabricate synthesized
and.and test organic solar cells fuel
cells is a fundamental area and we have
a fuel cell test station batteries we
have a battery line where we can do
testing and then of course we generate
materials such as catalysts for biomass
convert conversion and so our lab we can
do each of these things in our lab we
have people that have expertise in all
of these areas and we use various
techniques to look at structure property
relationships of these nanomaterials
that we put together so whether it's
micro fabrication layer by layer
assembly inkjet printing which I'll talk
a little bit about or nano imprint
lithography and so just to kind of walk
you whew whew whew whew walk you through
a few of these things this is right here
this is a silicon-based micro fuel cell
right here this is starting with silicon
this has integrated heaters temperature
sensors this image didn't quite come out
as well on the projector but this is
carbon nanotubes with zinc oxide
decorated on the surface so we can
decorate carbon nanotubes with various
transition metals we've done that for
fuel cell applications with batting with
platinum we can do it with ruthenium we
can also do it for biomass conversion
decorating these with nickel and also
with transition metals and alloy with
lithium so we can actually decorate
these with 10 and and not only that but
we also do the arrangement of these
materials so use techniques such as
layer by layer assembly this is a
free-standing film using a layer by
layer we use different charged
polyelectrolytes so the the idea here is
if you look at this and I thought this
is it was a good example just to show
the the problem and the issues with
batteries and energy storage so if you
look at this pill right here this is
Phillips intelligent pill right here is
this the the I pill right here and so
this pill right here so so it's 11 x 26
capsule has a microprocessor has a pH
Center sensor temperature sensor RF
transmitter transceiver you have a fluid
pump any apps will have a drug reservoir
for delivery and the idea is you can
actually take this pill put this inside
it can pass through the body hopefully
it doesn't you know impede but you can
also maybe deliver some sort of drug you
have a camera in the system as well lens
holder CMOS imagery
this issue right here this battery if
you look at at this right here so these
are the different different parts so you
look at this optical dome you look at
this lens holder the lens look at this
battery right here is huge takes up a
huge amount of real estate of this pill
right here and so if you imagine if you
scale this up because people are talking
about large-scale energy storage look at
this if we can't do this for a miniature
pill with with small energy requirements
then think about these large-scale
energy energy storage problems that we
have and that's that's one of the issues
that's why you don't see batteries that
are being used for large-scale
applications and that's that's a major
issue and and and so it takes up forty
percent of this real estate and so so
just to kind of cover a few things like
why lithium-ion batteries which what
we're looking at in our group we're
using inkjet printing as a technique to
to deposit materials and then also the
synthesis of the these materials for for
wafer level and I'll talk a little bit
about some of our future directions that
our group is going in but if you look at
the kind of the progression of battery
chemistry and technologies if you look
here there's lead acid battery right
here nickel cadmium nickel metal hydride
let's say for example if you had a
camera or cell phone that maybe I would
say maybe 2004-2005 if people still have
those then probably use nickel metal
hydride now the majority of phones are
using lithium ion and so there's
different lithium ion chemistry's and
the advantage with lithium ion is of
course you can have higher voltage
higher energy density lightweight longer
shelf life and then you can go through
through a wider temperature range and so
we looked at this we said there might be
an applet ear ight here for using
different techniques such as micro
fabrication and so just to kind of show
you a little bit just to kind of walk
you through briefly forest gave games
gave some details on how batteries work
but essentially if you have this lithium
ion you have a mobile ion which is
lithium right here which transport so
between charge and discharge so for
example if you're charging your battery
you have lithium that moves forward sits
in these interstitial sites if you
discharge your lithium moves moves it
moves across to your cathode side
releases electrons electrons travel
through this external load right here
which is your power requirement and
that's essentially how they work and so
so
so so it becomes a materials mixture
issues so you have different regions you
have your a node you have your your
separator region and then you have your
cathode and each of these materials have
specific functionalities that that that
we make for these and so this right here
is isn't isn't what we're trying to do
right here we're trying to actually take
a lithium-ion battery fabricate this on
chip for for small applications where we
can actually use these as thin film so
these are 1.55 microns and one and a
half microns right here and we're
actually working with wafer scale
packaging to to to integrate that
together now just to kind of walk you
through briefly on what we're doing with
inkjet printing the advantage of the
inkjet printing is that it's an additive
process and so in terms of looking at
nano manufacturing inkjet printing of
course was developed in the 80s and then
and the 90s people started looking at
other applications for example this the
alleged structure right here is created
using inkjet printing and so we're
looking at Egypt printing to actually
fabricate these batteries and put these
in so the idea is if you understand the
the chemistry of the inkjet printing
system if you have Pico leader volume
control for your inkjet printer then you
can have control of the amount of
materials now remember you want to
control the amount of materials because
when you normalize your your performance
of your battery your capacity by the
mass of material then that becomes
important and that's how you how you
write this material and so we've
actually used this technique right here
for for fuel cell applications this is
the interfacial area catalyst area for
fuel cell right here and so reducing
catalyst layer thickness right here and
and what we did right here is we imposed
a gradient right here using different
levels of platinum if you can imagine a
battery most people use just a uniform
layer for batteries if you can actually
put in a gradient for a battery you
might actually get a better performance
and this just kind of shows the two
performances between these two graded
catalysts and standard catalysts now
just to show you some examples these are
inkjet printed anodes right here that
we've produced in our lab right here
this is after about 30 passes we also
have inkjet printed cathodes right here
this is after 30 passes this is on
aluminum aluminum
thin-film system right here and that's
the thickness after about 30 passes
cross sectional area now an area for
improvement for batteries is is looking
at materials an alloy with lithium and
so if you can find a material the alloys
very well with lithium then then then
you're you're much better off and if you
look at silicon silicon is off the
charts right here compared to these
other elements that the alloy of lithium
so about 4200 milliamp hours per gram
but the problem with lithium is that in
bulk form then it goes through huge
volume expansion about four hundred
percent volume expansions when it went
alloys once it goes through that and
then if you do a discharge then it
becomes polarized it breaks apart the
material loses its integrity and so
that's the problem why you don't see
silicon but of course there's people
that are working in that area for
example yeesh we at Stanford he has a
nature materials paper that came out
where he created these silicon base
nanowires and and and they're still
working on that he has a company they're
trying to commercialize the technology
and there's still a few things that
they're working in in that area and so
like our group we work with carbon
nanotubes of course I mentioned we
decorate carbon nanotubes there's
advantage of carbon nanotubes and we can
decorate carbon nanotubes with different
alloys right here this is carbon
nanotubes we synthesized right here that
are decorated with tin oxide the ideas
these nanoparticles can withstand these
these volume expansions and and
shrinkage last part is layer by layer
assembly using different charged
polyelectrolytes it's been used for
variety of different applications we're
starting to maybe consider this for
batteries as well we've done this for
fuel cells and the ideas you can create
these freestanding films and the issue
and fuel cells which is the same as
batteries is a blending of different
materials and and and so we're looking
at that area as well and so this is this
is an example right here of a
free-standing film we've created using
layer by layer assembly using different
charged polyelectrolytes with
nanomaterials putting this in together
and then also creating a free-standing
film that you see right here and so we
can use different polyelectrolytes off
the shelf so if you can imagine blending
for battery different regions we have
the capabilities of doing that
within our lab the last part and I won't
go into full detail on this is there's
different chemistry's for batteries as
well just to kind of go into the science
and exciting areas these lithium-air
batteries right here and of course the
theoretical potential is you know almost
as high as gasoline that's very exciting
Forrest talked a little bit about this
and I'll be happy to talk with the rest
of the group in further detail but the
problem with that is interfacial
challenges interface your chemistry so
of course instead of having an oxide
which you normally have that that can
alloy with lithium you can actually have
oxygen that can meet with us but you
have to have to have this as a as a
barrier for water you don't water to get
in there so you have to have an
interfacial barrier so it becomes AF
fuels area materials challenge this is
our latest publication right here this
is coming out in the april edition of
acs nano so i guess in a couple days
it's online already and this is where we
use bulk metallic glass and a no wires
to to integrate these in for electric
chemical applications and so so we're so
we're rapidly moving in this area so i
didn't quite keep it all available two
minutes over but my apologies for that
but but we've kind of met the objectives
the idea here's persistence arrangement
assembly new materials interfacial
studies persistence right here this cure
he accompanied they've been working in
this area for 20 to 30 years might be
why they have seventy percent of the
market locked up and the last part right
here i just wanted to show you this this
this video right here if this will if
this will work i just got it took a
stroll maybe it didn't up see
yeah I just kind of took a stroll around
here and this is actually in New Haven
this is a windmill that they have and
what might not be hard to see I took
this with my iPhone and you can see
these tanks right here in the very back
and these storage tanks right here and I
think there's a very big opportunity for
large-scale energy storage and I'd be
happy to talk with some of you in more
detail but if you can see here these
huge oil tanks right here in the
background we have one windmill I was at
Case Western Reserve they have one
windmill on campus maybe that's becoming
a theme but in other places but but I
think there's there's a tremendous area
of opportunity where we can actually
move from this liquid fuel storage to to
look at storing this renewable energy
and then storing these these clean
electrons so thank you for your time
start the moderated discussion um this
Gary dr. Guerra more as a postdoc from
chemistry department and he will be
moderating the session and professors
please I'd like to start out by thanking
our speakers tonight for sharing not
only their time but their their
knowledge with us in the area of energy
so I think the purpose of tonight's talk
was was not only to hear the from the
what is essentially Yale's response to
what's been called the terawatt
challenge and research and efforts
occurring at Yale but also to the raise
the level of awareness of the audience
in preparation for our bigger meeting
next week and so at this point we'll
have a discussion panel where we'd like
to take questions from the audience but
I'll take the opportunity or the that's
the first question and this is related
to a question i asked last week to our
student speakers and what are the major
holdbacks that you see and removing some
of these renewable technologies for
words in other words what are the grand
challenges and why are renewable energy
is not a larger portion of our current
energy infrastructure so we could start
maybe to my right and and move forward
so some of them if I if I heard your
question correctly you're saying why
isn't there more of a thrust in
renewable energy exactly are these
scientific holdbacks policy holdbacks
possibly both is the scientific
holdbacks greater in the policy hold
back yeah I mean I think I think one of
the challenges is that in the area of
research and development I mean you
actually have to you have to stick with
it and so the United States and you know
if you look at battery technology United
States was a leader in battery
technology all the way up into the late
70s early 80s and what happened is the
United States kind of gave up on that
whereas you know other countries Japan
they started picking up on that they
started improving it they stuck with it
and and we've lost our leadership so now
you know if we want a iphone I mean you
know the company in Japan they make it
specifically there in Japan and and and
and that's why you know everyone's kind
of kind of worried that's why the Apple
stock price took a dip but but I think
it's definitely coupled with politics
because it's all in all in the winds of
change because you know for example my
area which which I started out in which
is which was in fuel cells that was very
well funded and then you know when
things kind of happened you know for
example Steve Chu when he came in he was
more interested in batteries and of
course there's a big battery thrust
program at Lawrence Berkeley National
Labs and then all the money started
coming in you know with batteries
commercialization and that sort of thing
and so I think those are those are some
of the challenges is kind of the winds
of time and what what different
technology areas are able to deliver so
I mean you know fuel cells was an area
that was overhyped and maybe under
delivered in some regards and then
that's what kind of you know kind of
changed some of that some of that
attitude towards that Thanks I mean I
guess it's sort of the you know the
comments right among all all of these
technologies is our political system
isn't good at making long-term
investments or thinking too far into the
future and the the barrier is specific
to to bioenergy but they're different
for different types of energy for
instance you know ethanol production
from from from cellulose or or
you know my curfew for microalgae
ethanol production from one that many
many other ways that you can produce
methanol or ethanol are all cost
barriers right now it just costs too
much money to to make a gallon of
ethanol or biodiesel from these types
products the costs I don't think are
insurmountable but they're large
challenges and they'll take a sustained
long effort in order to get past them
yeah like I think it's entirely
economics and gasoline is just too cheap
right now to make it viable these other
technologies are just a lot more
expensive than so that's partly a
research problem we need to come up with
ways to make it work better and more
cheaply if we had a you know if we had a
solar fuel device that put out fuel at
you know three and a half dollars a
gallon we it would it would it would
happen but it's much more expensive than
that now but it's also partly I think a
policy issue too because we need some
leadership to move forward on these
pushing for more renewables and it's
slowly happening but I think economics
is holding it up so lithium is the is
the is the biggest dog on the block when
it comes to electron transfer and that's
why everybody is that's why we're using
it but yes pretty much yes that's us you
cited them with you hey can we clarify
the question is if I show more related
to energy density or yeah I'm you know
in terms of why we're focused on lithium
for batteries is it just because of that
we've reached the point where we're
comfortable in producing lithium type
batteries or is it because lithium is
will be the you know it it allows for
the greatest electron transfer you know
for energy both for storage and an
energy and generation went from
batteries
yeah so so so if you if you kind of look
at look at so that that chart that I put
up where you saw the lead-acid the
recommended I Drive the kind of
progression I mean the the issue with
lithium I mean of course before they
started figuring out the the solving the
challenges of me and of course if you
can remember some of the laptops I
caught on fire you know because of
overcharging that sort of thing so so I
mean you know once they started figuring
out those systems and keep being able to
keep those isolated where there's where
moisture doesn't build up and that sort
of thing then that's when it actually
became the the chemistry of choice and
and so now I mean you can start seeing
it in more robust areas so for example
you can see it readily and in cameras
but now it's starting to creep in areas
for example power tools and now people
such a lot yet min Qiang that's coming
here they're looking at lithium
chemistry's for four batteries and
because you know they've become more
stable where you can you know you know
go back and forth and of course lithium
is the lightest metal so and in lithium
is found where I mean I know that we
found a lot of it in Afghanistan you
know do you is there a connection to the
geopolitics of moving in the direction
of lithium production let's Ian
batteries and what what does that imply
for you know interventions around the
world yes that that's a very good
question I don't know offhand the top
lithium producers but I do know that the
supply has been project I've seen in a
few reports it's been a project as being
relatively stable so there's there's no
projective shortage of it that I can see
question in the back my question has to
do with the two things that I heard
tonight and that was questions mainly do
with algae but when I was hearing about
solar production fuels the ten percent
number got thrown out and rather than
sticking with specific numbers that
seems to be an order of magnitude higher
than my knowledge of how efficient
plants usually are in terms of
converting energy and so I'm curious
what what kind of feasibility issues
that might be turned into when you think
about using algae to create things like
transportation fuels for a whole society
yeah maybe I can speak to that first I
was part of a deal we workshop about a
year and a half ago that was convened to
actually address the efficiency of
photosynthesis and plants and and
project how it might be improved in the
future in contrast to the efficiency of
photovoltaics photovoltaics efficiencies
are pretty well defined and either
so-called Shockley Qwaser limit that
says for the single Junction device you
can do about 31 or 32 percent conversion
efficiency and I think the number that
that that represents is how much of the
total solar spectrum if you take that
entire solar spectrum how much of that
can be converted into whatever form of
energy electricity or fuel if you take
that same criteria and asking them what
what our plants currently doing is they
well let's grow corn for a growing
season the efficiency for the conversion
is extremely low it's much less than 1
percent and under the best conditions
for plants to grow under idealized
conditions it can get it up around four
or five percent well actually that's
only in the algae are better than plants
so that but that's under optimum
conditions which you wouldn't maintain
all the time because it's nighttime part
of the time and if you're going to grow
them out in the field so so there still
is a limit for efficiency so one of the
things we also considered was how do you
improve it and you have to think about
the photochemical process
and that boils down to collecting the
solar spectrum better so plants have a
disadvantage that they don't harvest
most of the solar spectrum they only
they only go out to about 700 nanometers
and that wastes more than half of the
solar energy so one way to improve that
is to spread it out and so and they also
use to photo reactions that are
absorbing the same wavelengths of light
so instead of overlapping so that they
can complement each other they actually
compete against each other you know so
one idea we are going to we kicked
around was engineering a plant that
could have two photosystems that use
complementary parts of the solar
spectrum so that you would if you could
do that you would double the efficiency
right there so those are those are some
things to think about but it's going to
take some serious engineering to get up
to ten percent efficiency with biofuels
the bet that people are making who are
investing a lot of money in micro algae
biofuels is that a few things will
happen one will be that they'll be able
to leverage the byproducts that are made
from the microalgae that are much higher
value like vitamins etc and that'll help
us way to some of the costs
considerations there they're betting on
the fact that oil is going to become
more expensive they're betting on the
fact that we'll be able to exploit that
may be a greater than five percent solar
efficiency and micro algae and they're
betting on the idea that they'll be able
to they'll be marginal maybe fifteen
twenty percent improvements and things
like lipid production rate and the
energy amount that's required to extract
the lipids from microalgae so there
there's a few actors a few decent
economic sort of studies on this so far
and there's a lot of different things
that they're betting on some some come
up but mostly they're people are
positive about it you know what are one
of the things that that we discussed a
lot as well as in people may not be
aware of this but plants and algae two
are not designed to convert it solar
energy efficiently they're they're
designed to live and survive and
reproduce and they are optimized to grow
under fairly low light and when that
light gets high they quench at all and
so under strong light conditions where
you'd like to convert
solar energy into something useful they
dissipate almost all of it and so those
kinds of processes have to be worked
around in order to make plants more
efficient and actually plants are much
worse than that than lgr and and so that
because they worry about drying out too
and whereas LG are in water and so
there's a there's a lot of issues that
like this that need to be considered and
but there I think there are reasonable
strategies for engineering improvements
if I can interject on that one I think
another key piece to to keep in mind
when considering efficiency is only part
of the overall analysis and the other
part is cost so cost efficiency is a big
issue in bringing these technologies to
commercial applications so for example
this number of ten to fifteen percent
that's kicked around for solar energy
conversion photovoltaics well we could
look at gallium ten arsenide
multi-junction cells which have upwards
of forty percent become at a higher cost
and I think this is one area in which
biology offers at least inspiration is
how to use low cost materials for these
capture and conversion technologies
that's something i think most of our
panel would agree with another question
for mark
so hydrogen production through this
synthetic photosystem 2 step you know
this is you know what am I I barely
understand it right but the way I do
understand it is that you're stealing
electrons from some surface and then
you're replacing those you from the with
water right and so this is a must be
some kind of surface scale reaction you
know in order to make this a plausible
technology it would require tremendous
amount of surface right let's write camp
right and so can you go into how what
you're doing with that or what's what
what what technologies are being
developed in order to create sort of the
what I would imagine is a massive amount
of surface catalyst to do these
reactions on it that would scale to the
industrial loving right that no that's a
good point and mass transport issues are
going to ultimately become very
important so I can tell you a little bit
of maybe to get a little bit of preview
of how Nate Lewis is thinking about that
but it's it he's thinking about this in
terms of nano-scale design so he's
interested in building nanorods that
have high surface area that are
decorated with catalysts so they have a
lot of catalysts and of course then you
have to have transport issues through to
get the water in and oxygen hydrogen out
as well so these are you know these are
issues but they the same kind of issues
are also present in fuel cells except
that's going the other way and you know
maybe Andre could see a little more
about that but there's been a lot of
work done on nano scale architectures
for fuel cells at Mia for example IBM
has these carbon whisker technologies
that have all kinds of surface area for
for the reaction and so there's there
has been a lot of effort in the and
success and development of these kind of
nanostructures you know you it is the
thinking to couple these processes
because you if you're stealing electrons
from the catalyst and you're replacing
them with the water then you're doing
something with the electrons are you
moving those into batteries for storage
is that this you're going to couple
these sort of
of technologies well you could you could
imagine storage in the form of fuel
which is what I was talking about but
batteries yeah you got for me storage
too so that you know an andre touched on
that as well that that you could store
it the electricity directly you don't
need to do any chemistry right well you
have to do the chemistry within the
batteries but you don't have to do any
chemistry to to make a fuel like
hydrogen that you that you would use but
you're generating electricity by by
directly producing hydrogen is that
correct the other way around actually
using the electricity you generate with
light to make hydrogen right okay well I
guess I'm getting it backwards because
the way I the way I understand is that
you're splitting water because you're
replacing electron loss through that
catalytic reaction so there's electrons
or being lost off of that surface right
but basically what what you're doing
with light is you're making a voltage in
all kinds of any application of solar
energy conversion light is making a
voltage and that voltage could be used
to make electricity flow directly and
maybe charged up batteries or you could
use that separation of the positive
charge of the negative charge to do
chemistry where the electrons are making
fuel in the holes or the positive
charges are making oxygen so that that's
the basic idea again just that maybe if
I can interject and follow up on this
point with the batteries it's purely a
storage technology where's for the
photosynthesis and artificial
photosynthesis you're looking at both
capture conversion and storage on the
only storage end again you're dumping
electrons either into a reduced to
reduce a molecule to its reduced form
whereas in batteries you again you're
storing the electrons for storage
purposes but again coming back to to
energy densities Andre share was at a
chart it looked like that for the most
part the batteries were about point five
mega joules per kilogram so this is no
you mean the capacity for energy
densities for batteries versus a fuel
numbers are here are more around 50 mega
joules per kilogram and less of course
we begin to talk with things like air
lithium where we're now you come back on
board with about the energy of a fuel so
the chart that you had with which show
the the air lithium that was the the
theoretical but actually you know the
operational that that's been then
produces much lower than that yeah
well what would you fuel with this
hydrogen that you're generating what
would you actually run how would you
capture it you mentioned the engineering
challenge you have to capture the helium
of the hydrogen but what would you
actually run with the hydrogen yeah it's
a good question let me just throw the
other part of that out methane natural
gas has an awful lot of hydrogen in it
right and it's very abundant so what are
you going to do you produce hydrogen how
are you going to make a hydrocarbon out
of it or burn hydrogen I think there's
been a lot of discussion about a
hydrogen economy and I think many people
including myself are not too keen on
hydrogen as the as the end-all fuel I
mean it's an energy carrier but and it
might be the ideal with molecule to make
initially but ultimately I think you'd
like something that's going to be easier
to transport and and store and and so I
mean for example one option is to use
the hydrogen in in Fisher tropes
chemistry if you can make hydrogen and
carbon monoxide you can make all
hydrocarbons that's well developed
technology so that might be a better way
to go rather than trying to use the
hydrogen itself and as Andre pointed out
storage of hydrogen is a big problem
because the density of hydrogen you
store isn't very high so the hydrogen
might be just an initial energy carrier
and you might want to go and form some
product that's a little better behaved
at the end and on another front there's
a lot of interest in other reductive
chemistry's besides just reducing
electrons and protons to make hydrogen
why not just reproduce what nature does
and reduce carbon dioxide into something
like methanol or you know even higher
hydrocarbons that that technology
doesn't exist yet but there's a lot of
research effort on development of
catalysts that can do those kinds of
reactions I have question in the back
hi so I think you said that sort of the
government was taking steps in the right
direction for developing a better or any
energy policy that would clearly include
sound renewables policy within that and
I think what I understand to be one of
the greatest barriers to developing such
a policy is basic understanding of sort
of the technologies that are being
developed and sort of how energy is
created with these technologies or
tweaking arnis some of the energy
creation process is to create better
technologies and on the end of sort of
the government is funding a lot of these
technologies on one-off basis but not
thinking about infrastructure that needs
to come with it or the commercialization
side so I was wondering what you thought
the steps were being taken in the right
direction and what these look like and I
guess what you thought the biggest
barriers are two good policy development
with respect to biofuels solar fuels and
batteries big question so when we take a
first shot at it yeah I think I think I
think the biggest challenge I think if
that's what you're you're asking in
terms of direction of the policy is I
think we need more technical people that
are involved in the policy making and I
think that's one of the biggest barriers
because you kind of have this kind of
thing where you get an idea and it's
kind of might not scientifically be
sound but then people kind of run
towards it and then that's the new thing
and everyone's kind of jumping towards
it and I guess we an academia we kind of
do a little bit of that as well but I
think that's a major major issue i think
i think i think the the success
long-term success you know of scientific
research especially in the u.s. is to
have sound discipline to look at those
areas that that other people aren't
necessarily studying and keep keep
funding those areas i think that's
that's a big thing because i think you
know things kind of evolved diff
techniques that weren't available years
ago and now become available in now
different areas as you know move on and
I think that becomes an issue you know
the other thing is is I've kind of seen
seen a difference because you know as a
faculty member you're writing your
writing proposals for for thousands of
dollars right but whereas if you look
for example with batteries that have
been given to battery companies I mean
it's been millions of dollars from the
government and that's a huge difference
and the idea you know because it's
politically driven right we need we want
to become a battery manufacturing
country all of a sudden we want to you
know save our automotive industry and
those those kind of motivating factors
you know but I don't know how that
affects long-term you know our position
technically so a little bit of rambling
but but I just simply that I simply
believe that there there's some
importance of having a stated clear
national goal right now it's kind of
it's a bit of a free-for-all money comes
and goes people come up with good ideas
and go back and forth there's not a lot
of coordination and having a clear set
goal that everybody the entire
government or at least the majority of
the government could buy into is would
be a very valuable asset I reiterate
some of the points about sustained
funding for for research in these areas
is really important and harken back to
the Carter era and so there was this big
spike in funding for energy research in
it in his term of course he was a
one-term president as soon as he was out
of office the money the programs are
completely canceled you know so that
didn't help you know sustained research
and you know we've seen another spike
with the Obama administration and my
hope is that that's going to be
sustained this time and we're not going
to see a repeat of the quarter era hey
that
question off to my right yeah I'm just
like to comment to your question I I'm a
visitor here but I spent a lot of time
in Washington on energy policy the
president of the American geological
Institute right now and spend a lot of
time on energy policy climate change etc
the issue is not understanding the
science in Washington all these ideas
are appreciated by congressman and
Congressman have many of them do have a
science fellow who's generally a PhD and
explains the science to the congressman
or the senator the issue really is I'll
will this will this their major issues
well how this will help the economy is
it a threat to fossil fuels you know
will will the petroleum industry the
national get natural gas industry the
coal industry feel threatened you know
are we going to lose jobs if you're from
a state that produces oil and gas you
might not be too excited about new
energy technologies the other thing that
we're up against is fossil fuels are
very cheap and the public doesn't feel
the pain when gasoline gets to five
dollars a barrel the public feels pain
there are also budget issues and sadly
the National Science Foundation budget
of what about six billion is an easy
thing to cut it's a tiny drop in the
bucket so it's convincing the
legislators that this will really make a
difference it's not a threat it will
create jobs Tom Friedman has a great
book hot what is it hot flat and crowded
and he talks about how we have to out
green the rest of the world create jobs
with these technologies you just have to
convince Congress that this can be done
they look at the billions of dollars
that have been spent on new energy
technologies over the last 20 years and
it hasn't made a big change the other
thing you mentioned is one term tax
chain
stand and Friedman describes us in his
book the company in Ohio that created
the thin solar film couldn't get a tax
credit for more than a couple years the
German said we'll give you a 20 year tax
credit if you come build this plant in
Germany there's 600 people working in
Germany they have a 20 year tax credit
that drops five percent a year that's
predictability and and and all this is a
matter of scale if you're an industry
you don't want to spend the money to
invest it if the next Congress is going
to do away with your tax credit but
anyway bottom line is it's not
understanding the science in Washington
they do understand the sciences it is
will this science make a difference
thanks their panels like to respond yeah
I think economics is really what what
drives all of this and I think there's a
huge concern about the price of gasoline
going up in it having a big impact on
the economy and you know Steve to was
given an honorary degree last me and
some of us had an opportunity to meet
with them in the afternoon before the
before the day before and he was
lamenting the fact that even a 15 cent
increase in the gasoline tax was a
non-starter on Capitol Hill and 15
sentences not going to make any
difference at all on demand and so it's
just not going to the pricing is just
not going to make it happen
yeah I just had a couple of comments in
response to some of the other ones wants
the other question about one was about
the lithium reserves and it's my
understanding that the country of
Bolivia is exceptionally well and down
so it's just if you're interested in
lithium as really at a global
manufacturing level the salt the big
salt lakes in Bolivia are going to be as
dominant in lithium as say platinum and
palladium are for catalytic converters
coming out of South Africa it's it's we
are going to have to be involved with
Bolivia if we want that to be a secure
kind of resource the second point is I
think Gary you mentioned that the line
of reasoning that there's based on the
fact that we haven't adjusted the oxygen
level of the atmosphere significantly
means that we haven't therefore haven't
made any budge in the global reserves of
hydrocarbons because those hydrocarbons
were made originally from the paired
with the production of oxygen and I
would say the only flaw with that is
that most of the carbon in the kurth's
crust that's produced by photosynthesis
is actually stored in either carbonate
rocks or disseminated carbon throughout
shales that is not at a my noble level
so I just don't think that argument can
be used to as an estimate of reserves
but I'll take exception with the point
about carbonate rocks because carbonate
is oxidized carbon and you need reduced
carbon to balance the oxygen of the
atmosphere so you've got a redox
imbalance if you try to argue that it's
in the form of coverage certainly a lot
of carbon is in the form of carbonate
but the biomass that's compensating the
oxygen in the atmosphere has to be
reduced carbon not carbonate okay that's
fair there's also disseminated carbon in
and shales and think later but I think I
think the point you're making is correct
is that the overwhelming fraction of
that very biomass is not going to be
extractable yeah so we're never going to
get to the point where we could
enough to get rid of you know turn the
atmosphere backe anaerobic because most
of its not extractable and it's going to
get increasingly expensive to you know
to extract and you'll make gasoline so
that you have we saw the peak oil plot
here and you know that's real we're
going to petroleum is not going to be a
sufficient supply in the near future
great I I think due to time limit um
thank you so much for coming and please
join me in thanking the panel has to
give us this great discussion tonight